hey i'm professional cooker i can i can
survive in wood if i want
going down pocket bucket bucket bucket
bucket bucket
meal time is the best part of my day my
steak will taste better than your
strawberries i highly doubt that
we will see
i'm professional
no and i have gift maybe
he likes to try to make stuff but
i wouldn't say he's really experienced
be honest
you never see nobody cook like this ever
we'll see maybe he'll have beginner's
luck
when she try i won't she'll say the best
steak i ever tried in my life this is my
gold i don't see any fire trucks so so
far so good
[Music]
it smells nice but these smell better
smell this
let me see beauty this is my highest
skills by the way look at this i have
one idea competition what place you look
better
are you down for that i'm down i'm down
let's go
okay i guess they need to be somewhere
here
okay
this is my face when i play this is how
i look my hair when i wake up in the
morning how about the no playing with
food
this is the thief isn't it
uh-huh i'm actually pretty much done i
want a small lemon here ah now it's
better on the other side what is that
the this one the kids will love it but
you know what you miss it most because
it's a bow and face on a plate
yes
[Music]
[Laughter]
no we total
y'all look nice don't make me wrong if i
go a nice restaurant i want to see this
plate but this is something something i
cannot describe the kids will love it
they call bobbum face
oh like this is the steak to make you
wanna try mine i like this one
beyonce tell me your opinion honestly
it's actually delicious so what's the
secret ingredient secret is my uh it's
my soft touch
steak it's definitely handy to have a
lot of meat in the freezer
selma i like to stock up on quality meat
our body is much important and you want
to put like the best in yourself to
perform better
try my life the best i like how you put
all green stuff and join that meal
perfect free cook this for kids what you
think are kids like better yours
because it's childish it's good it's
it's for adult plate you know people
like but the kids enjoy too the look is
nice but i'll take yours okay are you
this sweet because i'm gentlemen